Wounded in similar ways, wounded in similar ways, it sounds like something that a hippie would say, but the truth is we're wounded in similar ways. Hey guys, it's Joel, and I'm going to try and do a quick little podcast today because I haven't done one in for a minute. People have requested that there be video even when it's just me talking and they seem to rank better. So yeah, even though it's just me today, I will put a video up if you want to look at the bags under my eyes that badly. Go for it. So today we're going to talk about ritual and animism and some of the thinkers that I like around those things. One of the things that I think is sort of interesting, if you look at, and you can read about it in my upcoming novella in 2026, but one of the things that I think is really interesting is the way that psychotic experience sort of informs, not informs, but lets us, gives us like secrets about how we think, gives us information about how we think. I mean, there's a huge history in psychoanalytic practice, you know, sometimes ethically, sometimes not so ethically of people seeing psychotic experiences this way where people's
“以相似的方式受伤”，听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话，但事实是，我们确实以相似的方式受伤。大家好，我是乔尔。今天我打算录一期简短的播客，因为我已经有一阵子没录了。大家一直要求即使只有我一个人说话也要有视频，而且视频似乎表现更好。所以，是的，尽管今天只有我一个人，如果你真的那么想看我眼下的眼袋，那我就放个视频吧。随你便。今天我们要聊聊仪式和万物有灵论，以及我所欣赏的关于这些主题的一些思想家。我认为有一点很有趣，如果你去观察——你可以在我2026年即将出版的中篇小说中读到——我认为非常有趣的一点是，精神病性体验是如何影响——不是影响，而是让我们，赋予我们关于我们如何思考的秘密，提供关于我们思维方式的信息。我的意思是，在精神分析实践中有着悠久的历史，你知道，有时合乎道德，有时不那么合乎道德，人们以这种方式看待精神病性体验，即人们的
ego is sort of turned off and they're able to just tell you about these deep archetypes and functions of consciousness. Like, you know, Carl Jung famously was working with people who had schizophrenia and he realized that they were telling him, you know, mythology from these really elaborate systems, some that had just been translated or were the cutting edge of academia at that time. And these people were homeless and alcoholic and had no formal education, yet they're telling him Zoroastrian mythology. Well, you know, how are you doing that if this is just something that somebody wrote down in the Bronze Age, and then that was a single experience? Well, it isn't, you't. There are perennial philosophies in how we think. And so not to go on too much about that. This, again, is about ritual and animism is this kind of belief that the world is alive. You see it in things like Japanese mythology. Like I just wrote an episode about Miyazaki, if you like his anime, you know, the guy who did Spirited Away and recently The Boy and the Heron. We have an article on that on the blog. But this idea that there are spirits in a rock and an animal and a
自我意识处于关闭状态，他们能够直接告诉你关于这些深层的原型和意识功能。比如，卡尔·荣格曾与精神分裂症患者一起工作，他意识到他们告诉他的是来自这些非常复杂的系统的神话，有些神话刚刚被翻译出来，或者是当时学术界的前沿。而这些人是无家可归者、酗酒者，没有受过正规教育，但他们却在向他讲述琐罗亚斯德教的神话。好吧，你知道，如果这只是青铜时代某个人写下的东西，而且那是一次性的体验，那你怎么会知道这些呢？好吧，事实并非如此。我们的思维方式中存在着永恒的哲学。所以，关于这一点就不多说了。这再次回到了仪式和万物有灵论，这是一种认为世界是有生命的信仰。你在日本神话中可以看到这一点。比如我刚写了一集关于宫崎骏的内容，如果你喜欢他的动画，你知道，就是那个制作了《千与千寻》和最近的《你想活出怎样的人生》的人。我们的博客上有一篇关于这个的文章。但这种认为岩石、动物和
plant in the weather even, you know, and we're sort of just in conversation with these things that I'm alive, but also the world is alive. That would be an animistic worldview. You know, slightly different from pantheism, which says there's like tons of gods, you know, everywhere. I mean, there's this like deep sort of natural world and all the systems that we inhabit are also alive. So you see in animism a lot of reverence for everything. They tend to be cultures that don't double down on greed or exploitation or killing the natural world because you're respecting it as a living creature that you are in conversation with that has power over you. Ritual is a different thing. So ritual, I think, is when you take a set of things, and it can be to enact what we do both
植物，甚至天气中都有灵魂的想法，你知道，我们只是在与这些事物对话，我活着，但世界也活着。这就是万物有灵论的世界观。你知道，这与泛神论略有不同，泛神论认为到处都有无数的神。我的意思是，存在着这种深层的自然世界，我们所居住的所有系统也都是活着的。所以你在万物有灵论中看到了对万物的敬畏。这些文化往往不会加倍贪婪、剥削或杀戮自然界，因为你尊重它，把它当作一个你正在与之对话且对你有影响力的生命体。仪式则不同。所以仪式，我认为，是你采取一套事物，它可以用来制定我们所做的两件事
at the same time, we're just fighting about the causation or the reality of it, right? Either a psychological or a metaphysical conversation that you're having through a repetitive or controlled practice, you know? So, if you go to church and you have communion, like, that's a ritual because what you're doing is you're saying, I remember Jesus had a last supper, and I remember that the last supper was a metaphor for him going to die for me, and, you know, his body is bread, his blood is wine, and he said this when he did this. And now we continue to do this in remembrance of him, you know, in the Episcopal church, that's what they say.
同时进行，我们只是在争论它的因果关系或现实性，对吧？要么是你通过重复或受控的练习进行的心理对话，要么是形而上学的对话，你知道吗？所以，如果你去教堂领圣餐，那是一种仪式，因为你所做的是在说，我记得耶稣吃了最后的晚餐，我记得最后的晚餐是他为我而死的隐喻，而且，你知道，他的身体是面包，他的血是葡萄酒，他在做这件事时说了这些话。现在我们继续这样做是为了纪念他，你知道，在圣公会，他们就是这么说的。
So, you know, that is a ritual where we are saying that this thing is connecting us to either psychological, uh, or a metaphysical reality or a little bit of both. And animism, one way to think about it is that you're taking your psychology, your consciousness, and you're turning it down. You know, your ability to be like, the responsibility is turned down a little bit of like, I have to understand the entire world. I have to know everything. I am the only thing that is alive. And I'm taking this image of this other person and this image of this other person and this image of the mountain. And I have to know how to build the engine.
所以，你知道，那是一种仪式，我们在说这件事正在将我们与心理上的，呃，或形而上学的现实，或者两者兼而有之联系起来。而万物有灵论，思考它的一种方式是你正在采取你的心理，你的意识，并将其调低。你知道，你那种“责任感”被调低了一点，比如，我必须理解整个世界。我必须知道一切。我是唯一活着的东西。我正在获取这个人的形象，那个人的形象，还有山的形象。我必须知道如何制造引擎。
And I have to – you're turning that down a little bit and you're becoming sort of like less conscious or less solely responsible for the conscious ordering of the world so that you can hear the rest of the world be alive. And you can – somebody may be listening to this and they may be pagan or lean animistic and believe in these things as a literal force. Other people are going to understand that as a psychological or anthropological reality, but that's the way to think about it. I'm turning my consciousness down a little bit, my inner voice down a little bit so that I can hear the world you take these forces of the unconscious, these emotional realities in the brainstem, and you project them onto objects to do a reenactment of something or to have power over something in this external way to later have it reflect this internal reality. So say I want to go do a spell, like I want to go down to the pagan store and I'm going to do a spell with some candles. And I look at astrology that speaks to the significance of how I do the ritual and I say, I broke up with my girlfriend, boyfriend, whatever. I'm very sad about it. I don't want to be sad anymore. And why am I sad? I'm sad because I'm missing this thing that is a part of me and so I take a candle
你必须——你把那个调低了一点，你变得有点不那么清醒，或者对世界的意识秩序不那么负有全部责任，这样你就能听到世界其他部分是活着的。你可以——可能有人在听这个，他们可能是异教徒或倾向于万物有灵论，并相信这些东西是一种字面上的力量。其他人会将其理解为一种心理或人类学现实，但这就是思考它的方式。我把我的意识调低了一点，把我的内心声音调低了一点，这样我就能听到世界。你获取这些潜意识的力量，大脑干中的这些情感现实，并将它们投射到物体上，以重演某事，或者以这种外部方式对某事拥有权力，以便后来让它反映这种内在现实。比如，我想去施个咒，比如我想去异教徒商店，我要用一些蜡烛施个咒。我看看占星术，它说明了我如何进行仪式的意义，我说，我和我的女朋友、男朋友，随便谁分手了。我对此感到非常难过。我不想再难过了。我为什么难过？我难过是因为我失去了这个作为我一部分的东西，所以我拿了一根蜡烛
and I light it on fire and I do a ritual where I say this is me you know this little candle and it's missing this piece so I'm going to let it burn all the way down and now that it's burning all the way down and going out I'm going to get another candle so this represents you know this depleted and reduced and depressed and sad me that has been burned all the way down to the ground over the time that I've done my drum circle ritual represents the old me. And I'm going to light this new candle, which represents the new me and all of its fullness that is now not missing anything that has been restored. And I'm going to take, you know, in the ritual circle, this old candle away, or turn the disc that it's on so that it's in a different position, and then put the new candle there. And what I've done is I've said, I'm no longer sad, I am okay, I'm enough, I'm whole, after this setback internally. I've said that externally, right? So that I can later say the internal reality that
我把它点燃，我做了一个仪式，我说这就是我，你知道这根小蜡烛，它缺少了这一块，所以我让它一直烧到底，现在它烧到底熄灭了，我要拿另一根蜡烛，所以这代表，你知道，这个枯竭的、减少的、沮丧的和悲伤的我，在我做鼓圈仪式的时间里，它已经烧到了地面，代表了旧的我。我要点燃这根新蜡烛，它代表了新的我，以及它所有的圆满，现在不再缺少任何东西，已经恢复了。我要在仪式圈里，把这根旧蜡烛拿走，或者转动它所在的圆盘，让它处于不同的位置，然后把新蜡烛放在那里。我所做的是，我说，我不再难过了，我很好，我足够了，我完整了，在这次内在的挫折之后。我在外部说了这一点，对吧？这样我以后可以说，我正在做的这件事所描述的内在现实已经改变了。现在我可以把这种投射撤回到我内心，我可以感觉我已经把这种悲伤的内在现实改变为这种外部实践，或者这种外部的，也许是你想要的一个外部事物，比如一份新工作什么的，你正在做一个仪式来得到它。但这就是思考仪式的一种方式，即你投射在这些物体上，然后是内在现实，移动它们，然后撤回投射以取回，你知道，那个，那个，嗯，呃，你想要的改变。你想要从中得到一些结果。嗯，而万物有灵论是一种放弃控制。你知道，仪式是一种获取控制。而且有很多不同种类的仪式。我的意思是，
this thing that I was doing was describing has changed. Now that I can withdraw this projection back inside of me and I can feel like I've changed this internal reality of being sad to this external practice or this external, maybe it's an external thing that you want, like a new job or something, you're doing a ritual to get it. But that's one way of thinking about ritual is that you're projecting on these objects, then internal reality, moving them around and then withdrawing the projection to have back, you know, that, that, um, uh, change you're wanting change. You want some results from it. Um, whereas animism is a sort of giving up control. You know, ritual is a taking control. And there's a lot of different kinds of ritual. I mean,
这不可能涵盖这些东西如何运作的整个历史。但万物有灵论和仪式与精神病性体验的关系很有趣，因为你可以患有精神病并去教堂领圣餐，但大多数去教堂领圣餐的人并没有患精神病。我想，当你患有精神病时，你可能会患有精神病。你可能会有万物有灵的现象，听到本来不存在的东西在对你说话。但这并不意味着——我不认为每个相信万物有灵论、体验过它的人都是精神病患者，因为在我们发展的很长一段时间里，我的意思是，这一集是那篇新石器时代人类学、建筑学、新石器时代建筑学，关于支石墓那一集的一种续集，因为很多人
this can't go through the entire history of how these things work. But the relationship to something like animism and ritual to psychotic experience is interesting because like you can be psychotic and go to church and take communion, but most people who go to church and do communion are not psychotic. You could, I guess, be psychotic when you are psychotic. You may have animistic phenomenon where you hear things that otherwise are not there speaking to you. But that doesn't mean – I don't think everybody who believes in animism, who experiences it, is psychotic because for a large period of our development, I mean, this episode is kind of a sequel to that Neolithic anthropology, that architecture, Neolithic architecture, one about the Dolmen, because a lot of people
做出了回应，这是对那一集的后续。但请记住，在我们存在的大部分时间里，比如我们的人性，我们有点万物有灵，或者如果你想称之为精神病，那么你是在说人类在时间轴上直到相当近的时候还是精神病的，我的意思是比大脑改变的时间更近，所以那么我认为有，如果你想把精神病定义为任何参与宗教的行为，比如这个，嗯，我不认为大多数人会这样做，我听过有些人这么说，那么你必须看到意识的力量更多是一种文化现象，而不是进化现象。因为我们直到相当近的时候还以这种方式生活，那时只是有一些关于事物如何运作的假设，它们是我们生活的一部分，我们听到了。而早期研究这一点的人之一是詹姆斯·弗雷泽，如果你读过《金枝》。詹姆斯·弗雷泽是一位非常早期的社会人类学家，他正在经历这些不同的思维方式，并试图弄清楚是什么让古代世界的神话和现代主义的神观以及一切发生了变化？为什么人们现在的想法与过去如此不同？我会争辩说他们并没有真正改变。所以，詹姆斯·弗雷泽在1890年左右写了《金枝》。它引起了争议。直到20年代它才变得更受欢迎。但这是一项关于神话和宗教的比较研究，它观察了这些不同的模式和宗教以及人们相信事物的方式。他受到了泰勒关于万物有灵论著作的影响。
responded and this is a follow-up to that. But remember, for a large part of our existence, like our humanity, like we were sort of animistic or if you want to call that psychotic then you're saying that humans were psychotic up to fairly recently on the timeline i mean more recently than the brain changed so then i think there were if you want to define psychosis as any participation in in religion like this um which i don't think most people do i've heard some people say that then you have to kind of see that the forces of consciousness is more of a cultural phenomenon than an evolutionary one. Because we were living this way up until fairly recently, where there were just sort of assumptions
弗雷泽正在研究的一件事是仪式如何成为控制超自然现象的一种手段，你正在控制某物，然后你，所以他提出了这种同类相感的魔法概念，即同类产生同类。如果你用玩偶或玉米什么的做一个微小的雨水仪式，那实际上会，因为那就像，你知道，这个宇宙的更伟大的现实，宇宙会听到它并做出回应。在你对这个事物的微观重现和你想控制的宏观现实之间存在一种综合，要么是为了从宇宙中得到什么，比如物理自然世界，要么是在你内心的情感领域，或者两者兼而有之。我认为有些仪式，
about how things worked, that were part of our life that we heard. And one of the early people who kind of examines this is James Frazier, if you've ever read The Golden Bough. And James Frazier is like a really early anthropologist who is going through these different ways of thinking and trying to figure out what it is that makes mythology of the ancient world and the modernist conception of gods and everything, what changed? Why do people think so differently now than they did? I would argue that they don't really. So, James Fraser writes The Golden Bough in, I think, like 1890. And it gets controversial. It gets kind of more popular until the 20s. But it's this comparative study of mythology and religion that looks at these different patterns and religion and the way that people believe things. He's influenced by Tyner's work on animism.
你拿着那个小东西，正在模拟一种超自然现实。还有一些是你正在模拟一种内在现实，比如我想克服分手，或者我想要我的庄稼下雨。那是两种不同的仪式。然后有些地方，可能像圣餐或大多数主要宗教，那些持久的东西变得更广泛，你在做这两件事。你在谈论你内心的一种心理状态，比如圣餐或大多数主要宗教，那些持久的东西变得更广泛，你在做这两件事。你在谈论你内心的一种心理状态或精神状态，以及世界中一种更大的状态。有些仪式做一种，另一种，或两者都做。而弗雷泽之后的一个人，朱利安·杰恩斯。杰恩斯是那些我认为他正在观察某种不可避免的现实的人之一，你必须观察它。但随后你也会用隐喻来描述那种不可避免的永恒现实。
And one of the things that Fraser is looking at is how ritual is this means of controlling the supernatural, that you're controlling something and then you're, and so he comes up with this idea of sympathetic magic that like produces like. If you do a tiny ritual play of rain with dolls or corn or something, that that will actually, because that is like, you know, greater reality of this universe, that the universe will hear it and respond to it. And there's a synthesis between your recreation of this thing in a microcosm and the macrocosm reality that you're trying to control, either to get something out of the universe, like the physical natural world, or in the emotional sphere inside of you or both. There's rituals, I think, where
而杰恩斯的隐喻可能不是最受欢迎的。它并没有真正奏效。所以在76年，他出版了《意识的起源与二分心智的崩溃》，这是关于二分心智的。有一种观点认为，希腊神话中我们听到神，人们只是说，哦，祭坛在对我说话什么的，之所以存在，是因为我们拥有一个进化和生物学上不同的心智，我的心智的创造性一面在生物学上还没有与逻辑性一面切断。所以，它只是会告诉我信息，当我试图回家去伊萨卡时，我会听到波塞冬对我说话，在我向帕台农神庙献祭后，我会听到雅典娜告诉我我将赢得这场战争，或者德尔斐神谕，也许，你知道，这与其说是因为她吸入的气体，不如说她只是听到了
you're taking the little thing and you're modeling a supernatural reality. And there's ones where you're modeling an internal reality of I want to get over a breakup or I want it to rain on my crops. Those are two different rituals. And then there are places, probably like something like communion or most of the major religions, the things that endure become more broad, where you're doing both. You're talking about a psychological inner state in you, like communion or most of the major religions, the things that endure become more broad, where you're doing both. You're talking about a psychological interstate in you or a spiritual interstate in you and a bigger state in the world. There's rituals that do one, the other, both. And somebody who comes after Frazier, Julian Jaynes. Jaynes is one of those people who I think he's looking at something that is like an unavoidable reality that you have to look at. But then also you're going to be describing that unavoidable perennial reality with a metaphor.
神的声音更多。他说，在生物学上，我们过去把我们的想法当作物理现实来听，而潜意识慢慢地分离开来，变成了一种我们可以更多地忽略的东西。但它仍然在那里，只是我们不再直接听到它了。而且，我的意思是，这本书很有趣，取决于你想多字面地阅读它。杰恩斯去世时觉得他并没有错，但他并没有真正说出他想说的话。对。嗯，他的观点绝对是对行为主义的一种反应，就像所有的行为主义者一样。嗯，我想他说的台词是，嗯，他们通过忽略意识来解决意识问题，即你可以说你已经解决了认知和内心独白是如何工作的。如果你只研究行为，把一切都归结为经验主义，这很有趣，因为那是行为的研究和
And Jaynes' metaphor is probably not the most popular. It doesn't really work. So in 76, he publishes The Origin of Consciousness and the Breakdown of the Bicameral Mind, which is about bicameralism. And there's this idea that the reason that in Greek mythology, you know, we heard gods and people just said, oh, the altar's speaking to me or whatever. The reason that that existed is because we just had a mind that was evolutionary and biologically different, where the creative side of my mind was not cut off from the logical yet, biologically. And so, it would just tell me information, and I would hear Poseidon talk to me when I was trying to get home to Ithaca, and I would just hear Athena tell me that I was going to win this war after I made an offering, you know, at the Parthenon, or the Oracle of Delphi, maybe, you know, it wasn't so much the gas she was huffing, she was just hearing
认知的研究是相关但独立的科学。但别告诉行为主义者或认知行为治疗师。所以，杰恩斯正在做的是试图解释为什么万物有灵论和仪式消失了，或者我们与它的关系不同了。他试图将其建立在大脑的进化变化基础上。但问题是，这不是大脑的进化变化。这不是生物学变化。这是一种文化变化。因为这些万物有灵的状态，这些仪式状态，它们不那么常见了，但它们仍然是可能的，对吧？你知道，很多人给我发邮件说他们想让我去参加他们做的那个死藤水邪教。或者不是坏意义上的邪教，但有一个群体。
the voice of the God more. And he's saying that biologically, we used to hear our ideas as physical realities, and that slowly the unconscious mind kind of separated and became something that we could ignore more. But it was still there, but we no longer heard it directly. And, I mean, the book is interesting depending on how literally you want to read it. Jaynes dies feeling like he's not wrong, but he didn't really say what he wanted to say. Right. Um, his perspective is definitely this reaction to behaviorism, like all the behaviorists. Uh, I think the line that he says is that, um, they solve the problem of consciousness by ignoring it, that you can say that you've solved, uh, how cognition and the inner monologue works. If you only study behavior, introduce everything down to empiricism, which is funny because that is the study of behavior and
不止一个。很多人说，哦，我喜欢你的播客，什么的。我很感激。我不会去喝死藤水，但我可以想象，如果我真的，嗯，你知道，飞到亚马逊什么的，嗯，我可以在这种药物上获得非常万物有灵的体验。也许如果我居住在那个世界，与那些萨满交谈，长期体现他们的现实，学会像关闭我大脑的一部分一样去倾听树木。我就会开始知道，你知道，以这种直觉的精神方式，基于世界气味的变化，基于世界外观的变化，你知道，
the study of, I think, cognition are related but separate sciences. But don't tell that to a behaviorist or a cognitive behavioral therapist. So, what James is doing is trying to explain why animism and ritual went away, or we have a different relationship to it. And he's trying to ground that in an evolutionary change in the brain. But the problem is, it isn't an evolutionary change in the brain. It's not a biological change. It is a cultural change. Because these animistic states, these ritual states, they're much less common, but they are still possible, right? You know, like a ton of people have emailed me about how they want me to go to this ayahuasca cult that they do. Or not cult in a bad way, but there's like a group.
光线的模式，风的模式，你知道，我的潜意识，如果我居住在那个空间，就会开始直觉地注意到这些事情，你知道，如果我真的能打开直觉。当你真正打开它很多时，你知道，有这种未经过滤的信息，其中一些事情感觉像是一个信息或一种认知或一种声音，很多人对此感到害怕，因为那也是精神病，对吧？就像精神病只是在没有任何证据或现实测试能力的情况下知道某事。你知道，你的创造性思维只是想出了什么，但你辨别什么是为我创造的创造力，什么是我的感官捕捉到的外部现实的能力，只是消失了。你知道，很久很久以前，当我刚开始社会工作时，我有一个病人
It's not just one of them. Multiple people have said like, oh, I like your podcast, whatever. I appreciate it. I'm not going to go do ayahuasca, but I would imagine that if I did, um, you know, fly to the Amazon or whatever, uh, that I could have a very animistic experience on this drug. Maybe if I inhabited that world, talk to those shamans, embodied their reality for a really long time, learn to like turn part of my brain off and listen to the trees. I would just start knowing, you know, on this kind of intuitive spiritual way that it was about to start to rain based on changes in the way the world smelled, based on changes in the way that the world looked, you know,
作为实习生，他口才很好，而且他没有服药，患有精神分裂症。有一次我问他，我说，你知道，你总是告诉我你弄清楚了政府用激光在做什么，卫星就在这里，它会把这些话射进你的脑子里，还有各种各样的事情。你过去读很多书。你去图书馆，有关于跟踪骚扰的书，或者其他人写的关于这些事情的书。你会从中学习。然后当你的车坏了，你就停止那样做了。然后你过去有互联网。
patterns of light, wind patterns, you know, my unconscious, if I inhabited that space, would just start to intuitively notice these things, you know, if I could really turn intuition on. And when you really turn it on a lot, there is, you know, this unfiltered information where some of those things feel like a message or a knowing or a voice, which a lot of people are scared of, because that's also what psychosis is, right? Like psychosis is just knowing something without there being any evidence or ability to reality test. You know, your creative mind just comes up with something, but your ability to discern what's creativity created for me and what's an outer reality picked up on my senses, it's just gone. You know, I had a patient a long, long, long time ago when I first started social
所以你用手机上这些论坛，人们谈论他们是如何受到迫害的，你会通过那种方式弄清楚事情，但你已经在家里独自待了一年了，你没有上网，因为你没有互联网，你没有出去获取这些东西，所以你是怎么弄清楚的，你知道，只是独自在家里？你在谈论太空中的卫星，他告诉了我一些我认为是关于妄想的最好描述，从现象学上讲，你永远能得到，那就是你有一种感觉，你在怀疑某事是否属实，你开始怀疑它是否属实，但随后你只是知道它是真的，你不需要做那种弄清楚它的事情，所以当人们听到
work as an intern who was very well-spoken and he also was unmedicated and had schizophrenia. And I asked him one time, I said, you know, you're always telling me you figured out what the government's doing with the lasers and that the satellite's here and it's going to beam these words into your head and different things. And you used to read a lot. You go to the library and there are books about gang stalking or books other people write about these things. And you would learn from that. And then you stop doing that when your car quit working. And then you used to have Internet.
万物有灵、仪式、仪式，随便什么，你知道，宗教体验，我认为很多时候他们认为你必须很蠢或者你必须有妄想才能参与这些事情，事实并非如此。我的意思是，无论如何，我甚至不是真的在说这是否是一件好事或坏事。我的意思是，我认为多尊重一点地球，把它当作一个我们正在与之交流的生命系统来对待，可能会让我们的物种延续得更久一点。但我甚至不是在说，你知道，你的宗教体验应该是什么，或者我们的关系应该是什么。我只是说，这些心态的进化能力仍然存在
So you get on your phone and you'd get on these forums and people talk about how they were persecuted and you would figure things out that way but you've just kind of been in your house alone for a year you haven't gotten on the internet because you hadn't had it you hadn't gone out to the get these things so how do you how are you figuring this out you know just alone in your house you're talking about satellites in space and he told me something that is the best description of a delusion I think phenomenologically you're ever going to get which was you get that feeling where you're wondering if something is true and you start wondering if it's true or not but then you just know that it is and you don't have to do that thing where you figure it out so when you when people hear
在这个物种中。就像我们仍然，我们想说，好吧，我们是现代的，他们过去是古代的，但那种变化是文化的。它不是环境的。我的意思是，它是环境的，它不是生物学的。你知道，现代人和古代人是一样的。所以我们有这些状态的能力。我过去在写《蜘蛛与鸟屋》时，那就像，嗯，呃，我出版的一本中篇小说。
animism ritual ritual, whatever, you know, religious experience, I think a lot of times they think you have to be stupid or you have to be delusional to participate in these things, which it isn't. I mean, whether or not, and I'm not even really saying if it's a good thing or a bad thing. I mean, I think respecting the planet a little bit more, treating it like a living system that we are in communication with might prolong our species a little bit longer. But I'm not even saying, you know, what your religious experience should be or what our relationship should be. I'm just saying that the evolutionary capacity for these states of mind is still present
它本应在今年夏天出版，但实际上是明年夏天出版。现在，嗯，出版商想，等待。所以当我在写那个的时候，有所有这些研究的巨大元分析，
in the species. Like we are still, we want to say, okay, we're modern and they used to be ancient, but that change is cultural. It's not environmental. I mean, it's environmental, it's not biological. You know, the modern human and the ancient human are the same. And so we have the capacity for these states. And I used when I wrote the spider in the birdhouse, which is like, um, uh, a novella that I had published.
嗯，关于政府委托的关于精神病的，追溯到很久以前。它是为某个——可能是NIS什么的支付的。我不记得了。我不再有引用了。我是在读研究生时做这个的。但有一个关于美国精神病进化的巨大研究。以及你作为一个行为主义者如何阅读它，而你不改变你的想法
It's supposed to come out this summer, but it's actually coming out next summer. Now, um, the publisher wanted to, to wait. so when I was writing that, there's this huge meta analysis of like all of these studies,
我不明白，嗯，但其中一件事是，你知道，本质上，像前——像大萧条前的精神病状态看起来很像万物有灵论，人们只是对那些具有祖先或地理特征的事物说话，所以你会有人只是说，他们正在与他们母亲或曾祖母的灵魂交谈，你知道，有些东西只是具有祖先或地理特征。所以你会有人只是说，他们正在与他们母亲或曾祖母的灵魂交谈，你知道，有些东西只是突然出现，而且大多数，特别是精神分裂症，你得到的大部分，
um, on psychosis that the government had commissioned going back forever. It was paid for for some – probably NIS or something. I don't remember. I don't have the citation anymore. I did this when I was in grad school. But there's this giant study on like the evolution of psychosis in America. And how you read that as a behaviorist and you don't change what you think
除非有任何药物滥用，否则它只会是听觉幻觉。你不会真正看到东西。所以如果有人患有精神分裂症，或者有人因创伤进入精神病状态，他们会听到这些。还有地理上的，你知道，住在河里、镇上的东西，你知道，这些东西的本质有点对你说话。而且在很大程度上，它们并不令人痛苦。
i don't understand um but one of the things was that you know essentially like pre um like pre-depression era psychotic states looked a lot like animism people just spoke to things that either had ancestral or geographic features so you'd have people that were just saying like they're talking to the spirit of their mother or their great-grandmother you know something just that either had ancestral or geographic features. So you'd have people that were just saying like, they're talking to the spirit of their mother or their great grandmother, you know, something just pops up and most of the, with schizophrenia especially, most of what you're going to get,
我的意思是，有时人们在患有精神病时效率不高。但城镇和人们以某种方式补偿了它。那些精神上的人或进入精神病状态的人会变得暴力，这种想法根本不是美国人有的偏见，因为这不是我们拥有的现实，然后在萧条时期，发生的事情在很大程度上是那些声音开始变成寻求帮助，它们就像它们很贫困，它们在受伤，它们很饿，它们累了，它们会问你是否能帮助它们，或者它们只是在哭泣。但其中仍然有一条同理心和同情心的主线。就像如果人们对它们说话或帮助它们，它们会很感激。而且，很多时候它们在鼓励你去帮助别人。所以它甚至不是在要求什么，它只是在说，把你的钱给穷人，你知道，拿条毯子。我能吃点东西吗？你能帮帮我吗？而且当我重新站起来时，我也会帮助别人。这只是人们一无所有的一种反思性文化创伤，但在
unless there's any kind of substance use, it's just going to be an auditory hallucination. You're not really going to see things. So that's what they would hear if somebody was schizophrenic or somebody went into a psychotic state due to trauma. Also geographic, you know, the thing that lived in the river, the town, you know, it was the nature of these things kind of spoke to you. And largely they weren't distressing.
萧条时期，他们中的许多人并没有绝望。就像他们仍然觉得他们会挺过去，大萧条的状态并不是世界永远的样子，尽管它改变了很多。当你失去那种更大的希望时，你知道，我不会经历像越南战争，你知道，像所有，有很多其他文化研究你可以在这里引用，不是关于精神病，但有很多事情在那个之后开始发生，嗯，在1960年之后，人们不认为世界会回到像过去那样好。你可以看到
I mean, sometimes people aren't as productive when they're psychotic. But the town and the people kind of compensated for it. The idea of the people who were spiritual or people who go into psychosis become violent just wasn't a bias that americans had because it wasn't a reality that we had and then during the depression what would happen largely is those voices started to change into asking for uh help it was like they were needy they were hurting they were hungry they tired, they'd ask if you could help them, or they would just be crying. But there was still this through line of like empathy and compassion in them. Like they were grateful if people spoke to them or helped them. And then also, a lot of times they were encouraging you to help others. So it wasn't even asking for something, it was just saying like, give your money to the poor, you know, get a blanket. Could I have a bite to eat? Can you help me? And also I'll help someone else when I'm back on my feet. It was just this sort of reflective cultural trauma of people were, had nothing, but in
当你询问经济时，当你询问他们关于他们这一代与他们父母这一代与他们孩子这一代相比时，你看到人们开始说，实际上，我很绝望。你在萧条时期看不到这一点，即使他们一无所有，他们是传播线，他们觉得船会自己纠正。所以当你过了萧条时期，当你开始进入现代主义时，比如在50年代和60年代，声音变得令人痛苦，它们是操纵性的，它们是对抗性的，而且总是存在等级控制、法西斯主义或种族优越感或某种权力斗争的主题。然后随着技术在70年代、80年代、90年代呈指数级增长，声音变成了关于深奥的阴谋论，用技术控制人们。即使妄想有宗教特征，也有某种技术监控。有一种技术元生物在我们周围生长，就像一个连接一切的病毒，我们无法逃脱它。这是我们
the depression, a lot of them weren't hopeless. Like they still felt like they would pull through this, that the state of the great depression was not the way that the world was going to be forever, even though it changed it a lot. As you lose that greater hope, you know, I'm not going to go through like the Vietnam War and, you know, like all of, there's a lot of other cultural studies that you could cite here, not about psychosis, but there's a lot of things that start to happen post that, um, post like 1960, where people don't think the world will go back to being as good as it was. And you can see
开始在精神病性体验中看到的东西。所以我认为，那个网站和其中的大量能力，特别是在九十年代，让你谈论你的宗教妄想，但也谈论你的技术妄想并将它们融合在一起，是围绕UFO的，因为UFO有点，它们填补了所有空白，而宗教或，你知道，基督教，美国人在90年代拥有的基督教范式无法解释世界。如果你把这些东西更多地变成一种技术隐喻，那么你可以做得更好。或者你可以填补那个宇宙学解释能力的空白。所以，就像，我认为你通过精神病所看到的是
that when you ask about economics, when you ask them about what their generation versus their parents' generation versus their children's generation, you see people start to say, actually, I am hopeless. You don't see that in the depression, even though they have nothing, they're spread lines, they feel like the ship will right itself. So when you get past the Depression, when you start to get into modernism, like in the 50s and 60s, the voices become distressing, they're manipulative, they're antagonistic, and there's always this theme of hierarchical control, fascism or racial superiority or some kind of power struggle. And then as technology picks up 70s, 80s, 90s, just exponentially, the voices become about esoteric conspiracy theories, controlling people with technology. And even if there's a religious characteristic to the delusion, there's some sort of technological surveillance. there's this meta organism of technology growing around us, like a virus that's connecting everything and we can't get away from it. It's something that we
改变的是，你正在看到人们的不安全感和他们对美国的恐惧，以及它是什么，以及他们居住的世界，当他们患上精神病时被展示给你，因为他们无法分辨他们的潜意识不安全感，你知道，他们居住的情感世界，就像杰恩斯注意到的那样，和逻辑世界。而一个隐喻，就像精神病，如果你辩论某人的地下室里有一条龙，这是你作为社会工作者最浪费时间的事情。你永远赢不了那场辩论。如果你尝试做心理教育，你说在他们稳定之前，你知道，当他们患有精神病时，如果你说，嗯，药物会把它带走，你认为你看到了那个，就像那个，那是，你让他们理智化，你让他们编造，你认为你看到了那个，就像那个，那是，你让他们理智化，你让他们编造，你总是会赢，因为你在辩论一种情绪
start to like see in psychotic experience. And so what I think is that site and a ton of the ability in that, especially in the nineties for you to talk about your religious delusion, but also your technology delusion and fuse those together was around UFOs because UFOs sort of, they filled in all the blank spaces and where religion or, you know, Christianity, the paradigm of Christianity that Americans had in the 90s was failing to explain the world. Like if you make this stuff more of a technological metaphor, then you can do it, you know, better. Or you can fill in the gaps in the explanatory power of that cosmology. And so, like, I think that what you're seeing through psychosis
你知道，让你到达目的地的那种事情，嗯，是当你开始说，哦，你，而不是，哦，地下室里没有龙，没有一群人来追你，你在编造，你实际上没那么重要，没人关心，你在说的是，你感到孤独，你感到受迫害，那一定感觉很糟糕。我想知道你需要什么才能感觉更好，你知道吗？我有时也会那样感觉。我们对我们的生活控制得太少了，不是吗？我想知道我们在这里能控制什么。你知道，我有时觉得，你知道，我想列一个我能改变的事情的清单。你是对的。你正在谈论的事情，也许我们无法改变那个。我们能改变什么？现在我是在他们将要拼命捍卫的情感真相中遇到他们，即我很孤独。我受到迫害。没人
changing is you're seeing people's insecurities and their fears about America and what it is and the world that they inhabit be shown to you when they become psychotic because they can't tell the difference in their unconscious insecurity, you know, the emotional world they inhabit, like James is noticing, and the logical one. And a metaphor, like the psychosis, like if you debate that somebody has a dragon in their basement, it's the biggest waste of your time as a social worker. You'll never win that debate. If you try and do psychoeducation and you say before they're stable, you know, when they're psychotic, if you're like, well, the medication will take it away and you think you see that, like that, that is, you're letting them intellectualize and you're letting them confabulate and you think you see that like that that is you're letting them intellectualize and you're letting them confabulate and you will always win that because you're debating an emotion
理解我。有一个系统在外面。现在它不是外星人，也不是中央情报局什么的，你知道，大多数时候，但那是真的。你知道，他们属于一个没人关心的阶级。他们是一群很多人并不真正在乎他们是死是活的人。他们是一个不适合这个世界的人，人们以一种评判性的、排外的、糟糕的方式看待他们。你知道，所有这些事情都是真实的。它们只是不像这个人字面化那种情绪那样真实。所以我不是在助长精神病。我不是在说，嗯，如果你吃药，它们会杀死龙。我不是在告诉他们这件事是真的。我只是告诉他们最重要的一部分是真的，这使得其他一切都无关紧要。所以我认为仪式作为一种心理过程是我以前写过的东西。罗伯特·摩尔是荣格分析师。我不喜欢他所有的作品，但他最让我感兴趣的地方是他有点像与维克多·特纳合作，研究仪式过程和不同的事情。有这种来自特纳的阈限概念，
you know the kind of things that get you places um are when you're starting to say like oh you instead of oh there's not a dragon in the basement there's not a cabal of people coming after you you're making that up you're not actually that important nobody cares what you're saying is like you feel alone and you feel persecuted and that must feel terrible. And I wonder what you need to feel better, you know? And I feel like that sometimes. And we have so little control over our lives, don't we? And I wonder what we do have control over here. You know, I feel like sometimes, you know, I want to make a list of what I can change. You're right. The thing you're talking about, maybe we can't change that. What can we change? And now I'm meaning them in the emotional truth that they're going to defend tooth and nail that I'm alone. I'm persecuted. Nobody
在仪式中存在这种过渡状态，人们处于世界之间。你知道，约瑟夫·坎贝尔后来会接受这一点并随之运行，即使他不会给任何人信用，因为约瑟夫·坎贝尔从未给过他窃取这些东西的任何荣格派信用。好吧，不是窃取，我的意思是，随便，你知道，这是永恒哲学。我想它是免费的。但他直接受到了他们的影响，或者他通过他们接触到了这些想法。阈限是存在这种过渡状态，你处于世界之间。在一边，你在现实世界中。在另一边，你在情感、精神世界中，但那个仪式或那种体验在它们之间。那，你知道，当我进入
gets me. There's a system that's go out there. Now it's not aliens or it's not the CIA or whatever, you know, most of the time, but that is true. You know, they are part of a class that nobody cares about. They are a bunch of people that a whole lot of people don't really care if they live or die. They are a person who does not fit into this world and that people look at in a kind of judgmental othering bad way. You know, all of these things are real. They're just not real in the way that this person is literalizing that emotion. And so I'm not enabling the psychosis. I'm not saying, well, if you take the pills, they'll kill the dragon. I'm not telling them that this thing is real. I'm only telling them the part of it that is most important is real and that makes everything else irrelevant. And so I think ritual is a psychological process is something that I've written about before. Robert Moore is the UNGN analyst. I don't like all of his work, but where he's most interesting to me is where he's kind of like working with Victor Turner and looking at ritual process and different things. There's this idea of like liminality that comes from Turner,
支石墓，当我进入洞穴，当我看到这些画，当他们读这份名字列表时，我现在不仅仅是我自己。我也是所有在我这个年纪时经历过这一切的祖先，在我出生很久之前。我也是我氏族的整个未来和所有将在我之后到来的人，我通过来到这个阈限时刻统一了现在和过去，你知道，那些是非常，嗯，那些是，那是你从特纳那里得到的那种东西，那种对仪式正在做什么的理解，你知道，比较宗教我认为与心理学结合得很好，以理解精神病、潜意识和你，你得到了像埃洛迪这样的人
that there's this transitional state and ritual where the people are between worlds. You know, Joseph Campbell's going to take that and run with it later, even though he's not going to give credit to anyone because Joseph Campbell never gave credit to any of the Jungians that he stole a lot of this stuff from. Well, not stole, I mean, whatever, you know, it's Perennial philosophy. I guess it's free. But he was directly influenced by them, or he was put in touch with these ideas through them. Liminality is there's this transition state where you're between worlds. On one side, you're in the real world. On the other side, you're in the emotional, spiritual world, but that the ritual or that experience is in between them. That, you know, when I go into
默查说了一些有趣的事情，但关于仪式实际上作为一种心理事物在做什么的想法，不仅仅是作为一种宇宙学反映，我认为特纳明白它不仅仅是一种，你知道，同类相感魔法的重现。这是你实际上试图把两个不想在一起的心智部分拉在一起，并忍受那种对立的张力或那些对立面的悖论，就像许多心理学家所描述的那样。你知道，阿德勒说补偿。荣格说阴影，你知道，弗洛伊德使它非常性化并说本我。但他们实际上是在说，在我们作为人类的现象学意识认同的最大部分中，存在着两种对立的力量。所以我得在一分钟内去学校接我的孩子。我正在想我真正想达到的其他事情。我知道，
the dolmen, when I go into the cave, when I see these paintings, when they read this list of names, I'm not just myself right now. I'm also all of my ancestors that have gone through this when they were my age, long before I was born. And I'm also the entire future of my clan and all of the people that will come after me and i am uniting both the present and the past by being here in this liminal moment you know those are very um those are that's the kind of thing that you get from turner like that understanding of what ritual is doing you know comparative religion evolved i think pretty well with psychology to understand the psychotic the subconscious and you, you got people like Elodie
当我去到石棚墓，走进洞穴，看到这些壁画，听到他们诵读这一连串名字时，此刻的我不仅仅是我自己。我还是我所有的祖先，他们在像我这个年纪时，早在我也出生之前，就经历过这一切。我同时也是我整个家族的未来，以及所有在我之后出生的人。通过身处这个临界时刻，我将过去与现在连接在了一起。你知道，这些就是你从特纳那里得到的感悟，那种对仪式作用的理解。我认为比较宗教学与心理学的发展相当契合，共同理解了潜意识，你瞧，像埃洛迪这样的人
Murcha saying kind of interesting things, but the idea of like what ritual was actually doing as a psychological thing, not just as a cosmological reflection, I think Turner gets that it isn't just a recreation of, you know, a sympathetic magic. It's you actually trying to pull together two parts of the mind that don't want to go together and sitting through the tension of that opposite or the paradox of those opposites in the same way that a lot of psychologists are describing. You know, Adler says compensation. Jung says the shadow, you know, Freud makes it very sexual and says the id. But they're really saying that there's two opposing forces in the biggest parts of our phenomenological conscious identity as humans. So I got to get my kid from school in just a minute. I'm trying to think of the other things that I really wanted to get to. I know,
默查说了一些很有趣的观点，但我认为特纳理解到，仪式作为一种心理活动，不仅仅是宇宙论的反映，它不仅仅是某种交感巫术的再现。它实际上是在试图将心灵中两个不愿融合的部分拉在一起，并忍受这种对立或悖论带来的张力，这与许多心理学家的描述如出一辙。你知道，阿德勒称之为补偿，荣格称之为阴影，弗洛伊德则将其性欲化并称之为本我。但他们实际上都在说，在我们作为人类的现象学意识认知的核心部分，存在着两种对立的力量。我待会儿得去学校接孩子了。我还在想其他一些我真的很想谈的话题。我知道，
I was going to wrap it up with Neumann. So Eric Neumann that I write about a lot, the origins and history of consciousness guy, he takes, he's got more of a philosophy background, at least academically than Jung does. Jung read a lot of philosophy. And so, you know, when Eric Neumann writes, you know, the origin and history of consciousness in 49, I think, 50 something maybe, but he, what he's doing is he's saying, okay, you know, Jung believed in introversion, which there's an inner world, and I believe in extroversion. Jung also believed in extroversion, where there's this external world. And he saw that people were sort of inclined through his personality stuff to notice one or the other more. If you leave me alone in a room, I'm very social. I get along with people.
我本来打算用诺伊曼（Neumann）来总结一下。埃里克·诺伊曼（Eric Neumann）是我经常写到的那位研究意识起源与历史的人，他比荣格有更深厚的哲学背景，至少在学术上是这样。荣格读过很多哲学著作。所以，你知道，当埃里克·诺伊曼在49年，或者50年左右写下《意识的起源与历史》时，他所做的是在说，好吧，荣格相信内向，即存在一个内在世界，我也相信外向。荣格也相信外向，即存在一个外部世界。他观察到人们由于人格特质，倾向于更多地关注其中之一。如果把我一个人留在房间里，我非常善于社交。我和人相处得很好。
I'm talkative. I'm highly motivated by relationships and community. But if you leave me alone in a room, I'm going to gravitate towards pulling ideas out of my head and then putting them on paper and then trying to chart that inner world and then trying to go somewhere with that. I'm not going to figure out how to paint a picture to show somebody later because I want them to see it or call my friend. That's just what i would do is probably something like this well i mean i'm guilty alone in a room now so you neumann is saying there's also this process of central version which is where a historical process where the ego was made where the self was made that as animals are evolving as the as the mind is evolving that you have all of these different
我很健谈。我深受人际关系和社区的激励。但如果把我一个人留在房间里，我会倾向于从脑海中提取想法，然后把它们写在纸上，试图描绘那个内在世界，并试图以此为基础去探索。我不会去想怎么画一幅画给别人看，或者打电话给朋友。我可能会做的事情大概就是这样，好吧，我的意思是，我现在一个人在房间里感到内疚。所以诺伊曼说，还有一个“中心化”（central version）的过程，这是一个历史过程，在这个过程中，自我（ego）被创造出来，自性（self）被创造出来。随着动物的进化，随着心智的进化，你有所有这些不同的
forces that are popping up these different um parts of self you know like i had to have a part of me that wanted to mate and and have offspring i had to have a part of me that knew how to like become aggressive and hunt and and threaten the people trying to hurt my offspring i had to have a part of me all of that stuff that gets watered down into evo psych bs and like repackaged on youtube by men's rights guys um like he there was this sort of archetypal unconscious energy when we were an animal and we were an animal because we were like completely part of nature and then slowly we became smarter and when we became smarter. And when we became smarter, there became so many forces, so many drives, or Jung would call them, no, no, no, I'm going to pick between these drives. I'm going to be something separate from them so that I can still hear the evolutionary language, but I can decide when I want to apply it and which one to apply when these
力量在涌现，这些不同的自我的部分。你知道，比如我必须有一部分想要交配并繁衍后代，我必须有一部分知道如何变得好斗、狩猎，并威胁那些试图伤害我后代的人。我必须拥有这一切，所有这些被稀释成进化心理学废话，并被“男性权利”倡导者在YouTube上重新包装的东西。他认为，当我们还是动物时，存在一种原型化的无意识能量，我们之所以是动物，是因为我们完全是自然的一部分。然后我们慢慢变得更聪明了。当我们变得更聪明时，出现了太多的力量，太多的驱动力，或者荣格所说的——不，不，不，我要在这些驱动力之间做出选择。我要成为独立于它们的存在，这样我仍然可以听到进化的语言，但我可以决定何时应用它，以及当这些
evolutionary forces are disagreeing with one another. I mean, if you want to look at neurobiology, I think that's extremely related to the development of the precuneus because the precuneus in the brain gave us this sense of self. You'll see like on a QEG precunial dysregulation in most trauma patients that have an impaired sense of ability to integrate self and world because this part of the brain is essentially like the hub where multiple other parts of the brain that have different agreements about how to handle information are crossing paths and being reconciled so like of course it's going to be a little stressed if that's a task that is impossible so what neumann is saying is that
进化力量相互冲突时，该应用哪一个。我的意思是，如果你想看看神经生物学，我认为这与楔前叶（precuneus）的发育极其相关，因为大脑中的楔前叶赋予了我们这种自我感。你会看到，在大多数创伤患者的定量脑电图（QEG）中，楔前叶调节失调，导致他们整合自我与世界的能力受损，因为大脑的这一部分本质上就像一个枢纽，大脑中其他多个对如何处理信息有不同共识的部分在这里交汇并达成和解。所以，如果这是一个不可能完成的任务，它当然会感到有点压力。所以诺伊曼所说的是，
these these things um these these drives needed to be forgotten by the mind in order for it to manage them. But now that creates another problem because when the ego is weak or the self is traumatized or the ego is turned off because you took LSD or you have schizophrenia or you have enough trauma to create a psychotic experience or maybe you dissociate when you go into lots of things, those forces become unmanaged. And then they start to be unconscious emotional reactions that can't be understood logically. And so the ego is going to be very inclined to deny them and say, oh, those just aren't real. They're not there. I didn't really say that. Or I said that because, which is what somebody with schizophrenia is doing. But it's also the way that everyone
这些驱动力需要被心智遗忘，以便对其进行管理。但现在这又造成了另一个问题，因为当自我虚弱、自性受创，或者因为你服用了LSD、患有精神分裂症，或者因为创伤足以产生精神病体验，或者当你进入许多事情时产生解离，导致自我关闭时，这些力量就会变得不受控制。然后它们开始成为无法从逻辑上理解的无意识情绪反应。因此，自我会非常倾向于否认它们，说：“哦，那些不是真的。它们不存在。我没那样说。或者我那样说是因为……”这正是精神分裂症患者所做的。但这也是每个人
deflects when I'm like, no, every single time in marriage counseling, your wife says this, you get upset. Oh no, I was just in a bad mood. I just ate a thing. Okay, well, 80 times in a row. Well, I just, okay. That's the way that all of us don't want to pretend that our emotional reality, you know, that archetypal subjective experience that's down there still has power over us. And if we don't notice that, we can't integrate it and it can't be something that the ego notices and uses. So, an anointment is interesting, origins and history of consciousness. I also really like Edward Edinger. I always talk to him or I always talk about him. Sorry. Yeah, I know. He was dead before I started doing this, so I haven't talked to him. But Edward Edinger in his book, Ego and Archetype, talks about how there's the ego and the self.
在回避时的方式。就像我说的，“不，每次在婚姻咨询中，你妻子说这个，你就会心烦意乱。”“哦不，我只是心情不好。我只是吃了点东西。”好吧，连续80次都是这样。好吧，我只是……好吧。这就是我们所有人都不想假装我们的情感现实——你知道，那种仍然潜伏在下面的原型化主观体验——对我们仍有影响。如果我们不注意到这一点，我们就无法整合它，它也就无法成为自我所能注意到并利用的东西。所以，诺伊曼很有趣，《意识的起源与历史》。我也非常喜欢爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger）。我总是和他对话，或者说我总是谈论他。抱歉。是的，我知道。他在我开始做这个之前就已经去世了，所以我没和他谈过。但爱德华·埃丁格在他的书《自我与原型》（Ego and Archetype）中谈到了自我与自性。
And I think that he doesn't mention Frasier, at least if he does. I've read that book a couple of times and I don't remember him ever mentioning it. So I don't think he does. But that's a weird omission in there because he's almost trying to observe the exact same thing he definitely would have known who he was but he's almost like he probably doesn't mention him in the middle and i'm i've just forgotten and i'm some i'm gonna be stupid someone's gonna send me an email but i don't remember if it is there isn't there edward edinger definitely knows who he is. I don't remember him mentioning Frasier, but so much of his work is going back and sort of like consciousness. And we kind of want to go back into this animistic state. But we realize that if we do,
我认为他没有提到弗雷泽（Frasier），至少如果他提到了的话。我读过那本书几次，我不记得他提到过。所以我认为他没有。但这是一个奇怪的遗漏，因为他几乎是在试图观察完全相同的东西。他肯定知道他是谁，但他几乎就像……他可能在中间没有提到他，而我只是忘了，我会显得很蠢，有人会给我发邮件，但我记不清那里是否有提到。爱德华·埃丁格肯定知道他是谁。我不记得他提到过弗雷泽，但他的大部分工作都是回顾并试图理解意识。我们有点想回到这种万物有灵论的状态。但我们意识到，如果我们这样做，
we aren't really alive in a way that we understand, or we aren't really conscious in a way that we associate with our identity. So it's this confusing experience, that kind of push and pull. But also that we have this objective reality of what I can see, taste, touch, count, you know, ego, consciousness, objective with a subjective reality of what I feel, a mystical nature of self. You know, maybe I can't see it, but I feel connected to the world. I feel interdependent on it. You know, from from an emotional relational standpoint, it is true that the world is a giant living, breathing organism that is alive because it gives us food and it's full of millions of networks that like coexist and talk to each other in order to take care of me and it is sort of my great mother because it lets you know like that that stuff isn't objective but it is still something that like is true right you know from a certain perspective
我们并没有以我们所理解的方式真正活着，或者我们并没有以我们与身份认同相关联的方式真正拥有意识。所以这是一种令人困惑的体验，那种推拉感。但也因为我们拥有客观现实——我能看到、尝到、触摸到、数出来的东西，你知道，自我、意识、客观——以及主观现实——我所感受到的，一种神秘的自性本质。你知道，也许我看不见它，但我感到与世界相连。我感到对它有相互依赖感。你知道，从情感关系的角度来看，世界确实是一个巨大的、有生命的、呼吸着的有机体，它是活着的，因为它给我们食物，它充满了数以百万计的网络，它们共存并相互交流以照顾我，它有点像我的伟大母亲，因为它让你知道……那些东西虽然不是客观的，但它仍然是真实的，对吧？你知道，从某种角度来看，
that objective and subjective mind don't know how to be in the same head. And that the purpose of what, you know, Edward, Edward Endgers, a Jungian, what he would see therapy doing is making them make sense, making them talk to each other and be on the same page. So that even though they're opposites that don't understand each other and don't value each other's perspective, there can be a harmony of that. There can be like a greater resonance in that paradox. Whereas with a lot of people, most people, they repress one and over-identify with the other. And then they resort to that other one in crisis. I mean, think of all the like logical engineer types, like the people who like fight with you online and are like, oh, well, you had a feeling there. That's an ad hominem
客观心智和主观心智不知道如何存在于同一个大脑中。而爱德华·埃丁格作为一名荣格心理学家，他认为治疗的目的就是让它们变得合理，让它们相互对话并达成共识。这样，即使它们是互不理解、不重视对方视角的对立面，也能在其中达成一种和谐。在那种悖论中可以有一种更大的共鸣。然而，对于许多人，大多数人来说，他们压抑其中一个，并过度认同另一个。然后在危机中，他们又诉诸于另一个。我的意思是，想想那些逻辑工程师类型的人，比如那些在网上和你争论的人，他们说：“哦，你刚才有了一种感觉。那是一个人身攻击的逻辑谬误。”
absurdum mistake in logic. I am just a perfectly logical being, sir. Like that person is emotionally nuts. Like that person who's pretending to just be a calculator when they go into crisis, like you've all known these people, they become extremely over emotional and then break down. And then a lot of times blame somebody else for that or deny that it happened same thing on the other side what do people who live in a mystical space that is very um just open-ended and subjective and totally about my experience that i feel at any moment when they're in crisis a lot of times those people become extremely logical and edward edward edinger in a way that is not fair or good,
“我只是一个完美的逻辑存在，先生。”那个人在情感上是疯了。就像那个在陷入危机时假装自己只是一个计算器的人——你们都认识这样的人——他们变得极其情绪化，然后崩溃。然后很多时候会责怪别人，或者否认发生了什么。另一面也是一样，那些生活在神秘空间里的人，非常开放、主观，完全沉浸在他们随时感受到的体验中，当他们陷入危机时，很多时候这些人会变得极其逻辑化。爱德华·埃丁格以一种不公平或不好的方式，
you know, um, like they cling to reason, um, as a way of making meaning when their preferred way of making meaning fails, because they don't have two ways to make meaning that we need as humans, which is the subjective and the objective, the ego and the unconscious self is Edger's perspective.
你知道，他们紧紧抓住理性，作为一种在他们首选的意义构建方式失败时构建意义的方法，因为他们没有我们人类所需要的两种意义构建方式，即主观和客观，自我和无意识的自性，这是埃丁格的观点。
So that, you know, Edward Edinger doing that, um, I guess is a good ending um i don't really have i don't have a lot more and i need to hop off here uh and go get get my kids but the the thing that is relevant there i think when you're looking at you know animism ritual whatever is we're never going to come up with the best way to uh talk about this we're never going to come up with like the best metaphor i think edgers may be one of the better ones that is out there
所以，你知道，爱德华·埃丁格这样做，我想是一个很好的结尾。我没有太多要说的了，我需要下线去接我的孩子们。但我认为相关的一点是，当你审视万物有灵论、仪式等等时，我们永远无法找到谈论这个的最佳方式，我们永远无法找到最好的隐喻。我认为埃丁格可能是现有的较好的隐喻之一，
but it is still real even though we can't see it you know this this unconscious and we've been trying to grapple with that forever through anthropology through you know uh evolutionary biology through psychology through anthropology through philosophy, you know, evolutionary biology, through psychology, through anthropology, through philosophy, a lot of the time that is leaning this way, that there's this problem with object relations where our inner world doesn't match our outer world. You know, the world that I live in isn't really the one I want to or the one that I feel like I should live in. And these two realities are colliding against each other. And we're trying to make sense of it by making these pictures of it. And maybe like instead of seeing all of this stuff as like as like right, yeah, the moon and the stars move around in the sky, but then Stonehenge also is able to capture and reflect and predict the way that the this day i'm still in the position of you know where the moon is
但它仍然是真实的，即使我们看不见它。你知道，这种无意识，我们一直试图通过人类学、进化生物学、心理学、哲学来努力理解它。很多时候，这种倾向是认为客体关系存在问题，即我们的内在世界与外在世界不匹配。你知道，我所生活的世界并不是我真正想要的，或者我觉得我应该生活的世界。这两个现实正在相互碰撞。我们正试图通过制作这些图景来理解它。也许与其把所有这些东西看作是……是的，月亮和星星在天空中移动，但巨石阵也能够捕捉、反映并预测这种方式……直到今天，我仍然处于那种知道月亮在哪里，
during march so i'm saying that i want the harvest to be good later on you know like a model within a model within a model you know a synecdoche uh when you have like uh things that are reflecting indefinitely that i make a representation of my own emotion with art and now other people can see it and other people are looking at my internal emotional world in this external world all of that art myth mythology the development of our relationship between the unconscious and subconscious you know unconscious and conscious mind i think that magic is in there um in a way where um what you're seeing is like cognition get weird. Like the brain reflect itself through metaphor in a way that like it can't quite understand, but it's sort of designed to do because that is like this greater resonance that helps resolve issues. And there's not a way to put that well. I mean,
在三月期间的位置。所以我说我希望以后的收成好，你知道，模型中的模型中的模型，你知道，提喻。当你拥有无限反射的事物时，我用艺术来表现我自己的情感，现在其他人可以看到它，其他人正在这个外部世界中观察我的内在情感世界。所有这些艺术、神话、我们无意识与潜意识之间关系的发展，我认为魔法就在其中。你所看到的是认知变得奇怪。就像大脑通过隐喻反射自身，以一种它无法完全理解，但又注定要这样做的方式，因为这是一种有助于解决问题的更大共鸣。没有办法很好地表达这一点。我的意思是，
I'm certainly not putting that well right now trying to summarize these things. But the point of that is that it's inevitable. And so we sort of have to reflect on it a little bit or learn how to deal with it. And when we do, you start to see, I think, religion and conspiracy theory and artistic practice and a lot of those things in a more gentle one, but also like more nuanced way. And then two, we see a ton of the people that are fighting about politics or fighting about religion or fighting about, you know, am I the victim? Do I get to be the victim? Are you the victim? Is victimhood real? You know, all of these things where they're trying to do this in this emotional way, but it really isn't about emotion. Like it's about their inability to, or in a logical way, when it really is about emotion, that we have this dual nature of logic, intellect, objective nature, and subjective, you know, subcortical.
我现在肯定没有很好地表达这一点，试图总结这些事情。但重点是，这是不可避免的。所以我们必须稍微反思一下，或者学习如何处理它。当我们这样做时，我认为你会开始以一种更温和、但也更细致的方式看待宗教、阴谋论和艺术实践。其次，我们看到大量的人在为政治、宗教争吵，或者在争吵“我是受害者吗？我有权成为受害者吗？你是受害者吗？受害者身份是真实的吗？”你知道，所有这些事情，他们试图以这种情感方式来处理，但实际上这与情感无关。就像这与他们无法以逻辑方式处理有关，而实际上这与情感有关，即我们拥有逻辑、智力、客观本质和主观的、皮层下的双重本质。
Yeah, and there's trauma and there's intuition and there's all this stuff down there in the brainstem too. You know, voices of self that both want to be heard. And what civilization or modern civilization did was turn a lot of the subjective parts of self off, or at least devalue them, you know, feel like they weren't as useful. And when it did that, it made them unconscious. And so you have, when I'm talking in the beginning about how people want to say, well, the ancients believed this and then we evolved. Evolution doesn't happen that quickly. Culture happens that quickly. And so you are thinking about when we look at anthropology a lot, evolutionary realities like they are, or cultural realities like they're evolutionary. And they're not, they're cultural. Our culture does affect us. It affects us more than we can notice. And kind of smushing these things together and sitting with them is one of the better ways to get rid of the certainty that leads, because the opposite of lies is the worst kind of psychotherapy. I think that psychotherapists need to be trained a little bit in anthropology, maybe a little bit in philosophy, depending on
是的，脑干中还有创伤、直觉和所有这些东西。你知道，自我的声音都想被听到。而文明或现代文明所做的是关闭了许多主观的自我部分，或者至少贬低了它们，觉得它们没那么有用。当它这样做时，它使它们变成了无意识的。所以，当我一开始谈论人们想说“古人相信这个，然后我们进化了”时，进化不会发生得那么快。文化发生得那么快。所以当你审视人类学时，你经常把进化现实当作文化现实，或者反之亦然。它们不是，它们是文化的。我们的文化确实影响我们。它对我们的影响超出了我们的察觉。把这些东西揉在一起并与之共处，是消除导致确定性的那种偏执的较好方法之一，因为谎言的对立面是最糟糕的心理治疗。我认为心理治疗师需要接受一点人类学、也许一点哲学的训练，取决于
how you think, in order to be able to help other people sit with these realities. Because we have to be able to help who walks in. Who walks in the room is different from who we are. And we are all creatures that are 100 million years old. We all have been on this journey for a long time, can partially understand it in our life, but we're still in communion with the way that we evolve, whether we want to think about that or not, we are. And, you know, again, you know, I'm a psychotherapist, not a priest. I'm not, if you want to take these things literally and interact with them, and that's helpful for you, do it. If you want to take these things as evolutionary scientific material realities,
你的思维方式，以便能够帮助其他人与这些现实共处。因为我们必须能够帮助走进房间的人。走进房间的人与我们自己是不同的。我们都是一亿年前的生物。我们都在这段旅程中走了很长一段时间，在我们的生活中可以部分理解它，但无论我们是否愿意去想，我们仍然与我们进化的方式保持着交流。而且，再次强调，我是一名心理治疗师，不是牧师。如果你想从字面上理解这些东西并与它们互动，这对你有帮助，那就去做。如果你想把这些东西当作进化的科学物质现实，
that's fine too. I mean, the result is the same, which is that we understand and not necessarily understand where it comes from, but understand how they affect us. So my point isn't to argue for what's real, essentially. My point is to argue that if you don't acknowledge these things, I'm not telling you where they come from, I'm telling you what will be real is that we mishandled these forces in our culture and in our therapy and our recovery. So, yep. Hope that is a fun, concise episode and answers some of the questions I got about the other anthropology, you know, Dolman episode, the dialectic architecture.
那也可以。我的意思是，结果是一样的，那就是我们理解了——不一定是理解它来自哪里，而是理解它们如何影响我们。所以我的重点不是争论什么是真实的。我的重点是争论如果你不承认这些东西——我不是告诉你它们来自哪里，我是告诉你，真实的情况是，我们在文化、治疗和康复中错误地处理了这些力量。所以，是的。希望这是一个有趣、简洁的剧集，并回答了我收到的一些关于其他人类学，你知道，多尔曼（Dolman）剧集，辩证建筑的问题。
Thanks. Signing off. Wounded in similar ways. Wounded in similar ways. It sounds like something that a hippie would say, but the truth is we're wounded in similar ways There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。下线了。以相似的方式受伤。以相似的方式受伤。这听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话，但事实是，我们以相似的方式受伤。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。